this is the soaring and sophisticated
rhetoric today coming out from the
president we'll teach Donald Trump an
valuable lesson don't mess with a women
America unless you want to get the
benefit CH and at least Biden still has
he has the intonation to some degree
he's still got the physical movements
the politician
gesticulations he just doesn't speak
coherently anymore he was never you know
he was never peric but it's like a baby
it's kind of sad but it's there's
something almost cute about it you know
when you got a little baby and the
baby's learning to talk and the baby
will mimic your fa facial expressions
and your intonation and your and your
Dynamics and volume so say what
your that's that's the president